so many people are being just robbed and
neglected from hearing about the truth
but you got to tune in today and you got
to hear this wonderful story so she went
from being an a really staunch Baptist
household Christian household to now
being Muslim when we say Muslim remember
it's very important these key points
that Jesus was a Muslim because a Muslim
is one who surrenders and submits to the
crater alone worshiping God Almighty the
same God that Jesus worship abc123
really straight for because Jesus really
was not a Christian nor was Abraham or
Moses they were all once who submitted
themselves to God alone to the Creator
they worshiped the Creator not the
Quraish I'm talking very slow and
explaining it because it's very simple
and easy to understand and you will find
this message over and over in the Bible
here o Israel the Lord thy God is one
now three and one Jesus when he was
approached and he said o good master
what good thing can I do them I may have
eternal life he said why you calling me
good there's only one good and that's
God that's the Creator and if you want
to enter into eternal life meaning
paradise keep the commandments and this
is what Muslims are doing and one of
those commandments you saw but the main
thing is before we get into the do's and
don'ts which I had mentioned these are
things that the Creator prescribed
because they're good for us laws are
there in the society protect society and
that's why God Almighty he had revealed
certain commandments to protect us and
to benefit us things that can benefit us
he told us to do and there's great
wisdom and the things that the Creator
has prescribed for us one of those
things that have been prescribed is the
immodest dress and you'll see this over
and over mention also in the Bible what
we have left there of truth in it you'll
see the call to do what Bianca is doing
worshiping the crater not the creation
and nowhere did Jesus ever say to
worship himself like she was asking no
where there's ambiguous statements but
clear unequivocal no what you see the
pure Menace message of monotheism that
Jesus called - and then you see where
Jesus's mother Mary what did she do she
wore hijab Jesus before he was born that
Jesus's mother worshiped him who was not
even brought into this world yet and
then when he was a little baby was she
worshiping him as a guy no she was
worshipping the same God that our sister
now is worshiping Allah Allah hah and
Aramaic the sister language too
Arabic I want people to see the
commonalities and to see the authentic
pure message that Muslims are upon and
you'll see in 1 Corinthians it says that
a woman who prays prophesizes without
her head covered she might as well shave
her head off she does honors her head
it's in the Bible it's there so bits and
pieces of it are there but has been
altered has been changed that's why the
Creator sent the Quran tamper free
tamper proof and it is the verbatim Word
of God and the final message of problem
Hammond peace be upon him and most
people who are sincere truth seekers are
seeing this the message is resonating
because it's straightforward it's simple
it's based on logical proofs and
evidences and you can go ahead and learn
more call us